hello this is Steve Kaufman
welcome to the linguist what is the
linguist it's a resource for language
learning I believe that people can speak
more than one language they can enjoy
doing it they can have fun learning I
believe the world will be a better place
if we all speak more than one language I
speak ten languages now some are Asian
languages some are European languages
Germanic languages Slavic languages
Romance languages and it gives me
tremendous satisfaction happiness as
well as social and even professional
advantages along the way I've discovered
how to most effectively learn languages
and the biggest thing is to simply have
fun and enjoy it avoid the complicated
grammar explanations and exercises and
worksheets that we associate with
traditional language learning in schools
what you need to do is to find content
to listen to and to read which you enjoy
which you have chosen and which is more
or less at your level just a little bit
difficult for you and so here at the
linguist we have lots of content like
that that you can choose and the number
of items we have in our library is
constantly growing a lot of it is
contributed by members of the linguist
community you have to listen a lot you
have to read a lot and you have to focus
mostly on words not on rules of grammar
yes just words how they work what they
mean how they work with other words and
all of the functionality that you need
to do that effectively you will find at
our related website which is called link
and there we keep track of the words as
you are learning them so you actually
find out how many words you know we help
you find content that is at your level
and then we give you a lot of tools
to practice with your words and and to
develop phrases that you can then save
from these words and that is really all
you need to do endure yourself and work
on words now this also is true when you
speak and write you don't need to feel
any pressure to speak and write but most
of us after we have listened and read
and accumulated a lot of words we want
to say something in the language we
don't necessarily want people to correct
us all the time but we want to be
improving as we use the language and
that is again a feature at link where we
emphasize the different ways in which
you can take the words that you are
learning and use them in your writing
and speaking and then when you go to
write and speak when you for whatever
reason don't use the words properly or
the way they're used by the native
speaker then we encourage you to take
these words and bring them into your
link system and work with them and study
them no further detailed information on
how to use link is available at the link
website here we just want you to browse
around see the content that we have in
our library for whatever language you're
interested in understand our philosophy
of language learning the importance of
enjoyment the importance of learning
words and when you feel like it go visit
that link you can register free of
charge and use the functionality that we
have there or you can also enroll for
discussions with the tutor or you can
write and have your writing corrected so
there's a whole world of language
learning awaiting you at link and you
will also there meet the rest of the
link community all around the world
people who are learning languages who
are helping each other learn languages
who are creating original and and
delightful content in their own native
language that other members of the
linked community are using in order to
learn those languages so it's an
exciting new world it's a different
approach to language learning it's that
one that we think is fun
and brings people together from many
many different cultures so thank you for
visiting us and please take the time to
look around